et notre invité ce matin c'est Cyril
chamanier bonjour bon merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
de la CFTC on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour on
va évidemment parler de Cyril Chabanier
de votre compte avec Elisabeth borne
vous ce sera demain en milieu de journée
on va y revenir mais d'abord vous avez
j'imagine écouter le président de la
République hier soir invité du 20h de
TF1 il a de nouveau défendu la réforme
des retraites réformes nécessaires et
qui l'assume à tindi il dit que le pays
avance malgré la contestation sur cette
réforme comment vous avez accueilli ces
propos
ce qui était assez insupportable c'est
d'avoir toujours le même discours en
nous disant que pour
financer notre système de retraite il
fallait absolument décaler l'âge légal
parce que les deux autres solutions qui
sont soit la baisse des pensions soit
l'augmentation des cotisations ne sont
pas ne sont pas possibles et acceptables
jusque-là d'ailleurs on peut le suivre
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui ça fait
ça fait 5-6 mois qu'on explique il y a
d'autres solutions pour financer le
régime des retraites et que je crois que
ce combat là de la pédagogie et de
l'explication il a il a perdu tout le
monde a compris qu'on pouvait trouver
d'autres solutions pour financer les
retraites alors qu'il fallait faire une
réforme des retraites on l'a toujours
dit à la CFTC que notre système allait
être en déficit dans les années à venir
on peut discuter du chiffre 10 12 ou 15
milliards mais on l'a toujours assumé la
problématique c'est que c'est 12 à 15
milliards on pouvait les trouver
autrement que par le report de l'âge
légal et c'est là où il y a notre fort
désaccord donc ce triptyque qu'on entend
depuis des mois et des mois que c'est
soit en soit en augmenter cotisations
soit en décalage là soit on décalage
légal pardon non il y a d'autres
solutions l'emploi des seniors on l'a
dit l'égalité salariale la
conditionnalité des aides revoir les
exonérations de cotisation d'autres
sujets qu'il a pas voulu aborder est-ce
que vous attendiez vraiment autre chose
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir ah non sur
les retraites on a s'attendait pas
s'attendait pas notre discours je crois
qu'aujourd'hui voilà on sait que le
combat qu'il faut mener c'est avec la
proposition de loi du groupe lot qui
sera débattu 18 juin et je crois que ça
sera peut-être un des derniers combats
mais celui-là en tout cas il faut le
mener on le mène fortement on l'avenir
on va parler de votre rencontre je le
disais ce sera demain la mi-journée avec
Elizabeth borne
de l'alliotte le 8 juin qu'est-ce que
vous attendez du rendez-vous de demain
avec Elisabeth borne il y a pas de il y
a pas de d'ordre du jour fixé et de quoi
est-ce que vous allez lui parler vous
alors il y a pas d'ordre de jour fixés
parce que le but de ces rencontres c'est
justement de pouvoir fixer ensemble
puisque il y a le dialogue social qui
devrait repartir si on écoute la
première ministre avec l'apaisement on
devrait construire ensemble un agenda
social qu'est-ce que avant de parler du
fond ça déjà vous saluer la méthode le
fait qu'elle dise à pas d'ordre du jour
j'ai envie de débuter leur priorité le
fait de nous dire que tous les sujets
sont ouverts qui a pas de tabou et qu'on
va construire ensemble un agenda social
jusque là évidemment c'est ça ça démarre
plutôt bien on va voir par la suite
alors on va lui parler évidemment on va
faire un petit topo sur les retraites
pour dire que pour nous le combat
continue le fait de venir à ces réunions
ça veut pas dire qu'on a tourné la page
c'est c'est évidemment important ensuite
on va parler des autres préoccupations
de nos concitoyens
ensuite des discussions parce qu'il y a
quand même peu de chance demain qu'elle
vous dise quand même qu'elle revient sur
la réforme des retraites pour vous vous
n'en faites pas un préalable à la suite
des discussions non parce que nous avons
des tas de sujets aujourd'hui qu'il faut
absolument traiter et donc mais c'est
juste que ça alors c'est pas un
préalable mais à l'inverse d'y aller ça
veut pas dire qu'on tourne la page sur
les retraites
donc les sujets à vous nos priorités à
nous premier sujet c'est évidemment
pouvoir d'achat salaire
quand on en écoute encore hier soir le
discours du président de la République
où on nous dit que les augmentations de
salaire doit passer uniquement par les
partenaires sociaux et donc par le
dialogue social entre l'État qui fait
tout et l'État qui fait rien il y a
peut-être un juste milieu je rappelle
quand même que déjà premier employeur en
France c'est l'état et que l'État a un
rôle à jouer dans les salaires de nos
fonctionnaires et aujourd'hui on est
loin d'avoir compensé l'inflation donc
et quand j'entends Bruno Le Maire
demander aux entreprises de d'augmenter
les salaires pour ceux qui le peuvent ça
serait bien déjà de montrer l'exemple
nous avons un sujet phare sur les
classification dans notre pays puisque
nous avons 150 conventions collectives
qui ont des niveaux de rémunération en
deçà du SMIC il faut absolument qu'on
règle qu'on règle ça des tassements de
grille
hiérarchiquesment nous on va demander
que les aides aux entreprises soient
conditionnées au fait que justement ces
branches soient mis dans la régularité
et d'ailleurs on va demander aussi que
les écarts dans ces niveaux de
rémunération reste stable quand il y a
des augmentations de bas salaire
c'est-à-dire que lorsque les premiers
niveaux avec le SMIC augmentent par
exemple de 2%, il faut que les autres
niveaux dans une grille de calcification
augmente aussi de à peu près de 2% sinon
on a un tassement terrible et
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises on a
quasiment plus de négociations de
salaire global on a uniquement des
salaires enfin des négociations sur les
basses salaires donc et c'est très bien
c'est une priorité je ne discute pas sur
ça mais toutes les personnes qui ont
quelques centaines d'euros au-dessus du
SMIC souvent on voit leur salaire qui ne
bouge plus il y en a un tassement donc
ça c'est important ça pratiquement le
conditionnement des aides aux
entreprises qui joueraient pas le jeu
sur le sur la rémunération c'est quelque
chose qui peut aboutir par exemple vous
pensez que là elle peut la première
ministre peut vous donner rapidement je
crois que ça peut que ça peut aboutir je
pense que la première ministre est le
ministre du Travail sont pas forcément
fermées sur cette position après on a un
problème de de mise en place c'est pas
évident de mettre la conditionnalité
tout simplement c'est est-ce qu'on le
fait au niveau de l'entreprise est-ce
qu'on fait au niveau de la branche il
faut qu'on soit très prudent parce que
il faut que on puisse mettre en place
cette conditionnalité sans créer de
différences juridiques qui pourraient
être retoqués soit par le Conseil
constitutionnel soit par d'autres
instances donc c'est pas évident à
mettre en place et ça demande un petit
peu de travail mais sur sur l'envie de
le faire je pense qu'on peut avancer sur
ce sur ce sujet là en tout cas je vais
pas préjugé des des réponses qu'on aura
qu'on aura de même et mais je crois que
en tout cas la discussion est ouverte
sur ces sujets qu'est-ce qu'il fait que
demain vous ressortirez satisfait de ce
rendez-vous à Matignon
ça sera les différents sujets qu'on
pourra aborder est-ce que sur les
salaires il y a un coup de pouce qui est
donné qui va être donné pour les
fonctionnaires est-ce que sur lesquels
augmentation de du processus est-ce que
sur
les sur les 20 dernières années il y a
une différence de 20% entre l'inflation
et le point d'indice il a été il y a eu
trois,5% qui ont été donnés on sait très
bien que les 17% qui manquent on n'a pas
le faire à une fois et on est on peut
comprendre ça mais il faut s'inscrire
dans un en tout cas dans un phénomène de
rattrapage il faut encore augmenter au
moins une première demande à 4,5% de le
faire en trois quatre étapes donc c'est
une première demande les grilles de
classification est-ce qu'on est prêt à
les faire c'est une c'est une deuxième
demande mettre en place la
conditionnalité des aides nous on va
demander aussi d'ailleurs de mettre à
plat toutes les aides c'est-à-dire
aujourd'hui on a alors selon les
chiffres on parle de 100 milliards
d'euros d'aide aux entreprises ou
d'exonération d'autres rapports parlent
de 160 alors ça dépend ce qu'on prend en
compte sans faire une bataille de
chiffres nous on demande à ce qu'on tout
ça sur la table avec la Cour des comptes
avec des experts
on n'est pas dogmatique à la CFTC pour
aboutir à dire voilà il y a des aides
qui sont efficaces qui sont utiles qui
ont montré leur effet on les garde il y
en a d'autres oui compris la Cour des
comptes démontre que il y a quasiment
pas d'effet je parle pas par exemple au
1,6 Smic de la loi Fillon qui donne des
exonérations qui créent une trappe à bas
salaire incroyable parce que dans
beaucoup d'entreprises 1,6 mm c'est le
salaire moyen en France donc dans
beaucoup de d'entreprises on veut pas
augmenter les salaires et en particulier
de ces catégories parce qu'on passe
juste au dessus des 1,6 et on a beaucoup
moins d'exonération donc c'est une
trappe à bas salaire vous voyez donc
tout ça il faut vraiment qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse en discuter puis il y a
d'autres sujets il y a l'assurance
chômage il y a la conditionnalité avec
le RSA on a sur le RSA justement
qu'est-ce que vous attendez est-ce que
là le gouvernement vous semble ouvert
sur ce sujet
alors le gouvernement est ouvert et moi
c'est pas le sujet sur lequel j'ai plus
de difficultés avec le gouvernement
c'est peut-être une différence avec avec
mes autres collègues parce que j'ai
inverse la problématique c'est à dire
c'est pas la conditionnalité pour
obtenir le RSA avec un engagement avec
des formations qui me choque c'est
l'inverse qui me choquerait c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui est au RSA doit être
obligatoirement accompagné parce que
notre objectif c'est de le sortir du RSA
c'est à la CFTC on est très attaché à
l'homme ou la femme debout donc on veut
le sortir du RSA aujourd'hui on a 340
mille bénéficiaires du RSA qui n'ont
aucun accompagnement tu n'en même aucune
structure de rattachement du
gouvernement mais moi je n'ai pas de je
n'ai très peu de différence avec le
discours du gouvernement sur ça à
condition que on parle bien
d'accompagnement qu'on parle de
formation qu'on parle d'immersion ou de
stage ça me va mais
d'activités de travail obligatoire parce
que si on est capable de donner 15 à 20h
de travail obligatoire on est capable de
donner au moins un mi-temps à une
personne qu'on peut compléter avec des
aides donc on sait pas un travail
gratuit ou un travail avec un bas coût
l'objectif il est pas là mais par contre
de dire qu'il y a des droits et des
devoirs et de demander qui est un
accompagnement mais ce qui devrait
choquer tout le monde c'est les
personnes au RSA qui n'ont pas
d'accompagnement c'est ça qui devrait
choquant donc c'est pas un sujet je
pense que sur celui-là sur lequel vous
pouvez tomber d'accord à partir du
moment où c'est pas des heures
d'activité des heures de travail à bas
coût on peut on peut tomber on peut
tomber d'accord et puis on a d'autres
sujets aussi à traiter qui sont qui sont
capitaux on a une crise du logement dans
notre pays aujourd'hui on a un système
éducatif qui est extrêmement compliqué
enfin vous voyez dans les dans toutes
les études qui sont menées dans les
tests on a un niveau scolaire qui
deviennent qui devient catastrophique ou
on est classé parmi les pays d'Europe
les en tout cas avec les résultats les
plus mauvais donc on a la santé et notre
santé au travail qui est aussi un vrai
sujet et puis je terminerai par ça ce
que vous voyez ça fait beaucoup de
sujets mais on va on va pouvoir aborder
un peu tout ça puis on verra les
priorités qu'on mettra même si le
pouvoir d'achat restera la priorité
évidemment on a tous les sujets liés à
la retraite qui ont été retirées par les
Conseils constitutionnels et qu'on doit
traiter parce que je veux dire même si
le 8 juin ont gagné que cette loi est
retirée il faudrait quand même traiter
ces sujets là je veux dire
vous demandez à Elisabeth borne de
revenir sur les mesures initiales sur la
pénibilité sur l'emploi des seniors et
emploi des seniors oui pénibilité
reconversion emploi des seniors et ça
vous en faites une condition oui mais de
toute façon
de revenir sur l'ensemble de la réforme
il faut au moins revenir là-dessus mais
je pense que alors peut-être qu'on sera
pas d'accord sur tous les sujets sur
lequel on veut mettre sur la table liée
liée à ces trois thématiques mais quelle
est votre priorité vous par exemple sur
ces sujets la priorité c'est évidemment
la pénibilité et et les reconversions il
faut qu'on essaie de de réintégrer ces
critères ergonomiques dans le compte
pénibilité wow anonymat de pouvoir
remettre ce qui a été dans la loi
c'est-à-dire le fait que
vous puissiez faire une reconversion
lorsque vous avez des critères
ergonomiques c'est-à-dire des charges
lourdes de des postures difficiles parce
que il y a un vrai sujet par rapport à
ça il y a certains métiers ou évidemment
c'est bien de partir deux trois ans plus
tôt à la retraite mais le vrai sujet
n'est pas là le vrai sujet il est qui a
des métiers on peut pas faire qu'on ne
peut pas faire pendant 40 ans parce que
même si vous partez trois ou quatre ans
plus tôt à la retraite vous êtes
complètement brisé donc on devrait
presque avoir des obligations de
reconversion au bout de 20 ans de
métiers pour pour les métiers
physiquement les plus pénibles donc ça
c'est un vrai sujet à traiter il y avait
aussi le fait que en plus on puisse
partir de manière anticipée grâce à ces
critères agronomiques alors nous on
voulait que ce soit réintégrer de
manière automatique dans le compte
pénibilité ça avait été mis par une
visite médicale et donc par l'accord du
médecin mais un minimum il faut que ça
revienne même si je trouve qu'on met
beaucoup de risques entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats à cette
question médicale
disons que c'est ça permettait un peu
non que ça permettait de remettre un
petit peu de prendre de reprendre en
compte un petit peu les critères
ergonomiques alors pas totalement comme
le souhaitait dans le compte pénibilité
mais au moins il y avait une possibilité
de les reprendre en compte donc c'était
une espèce de mauvais compromis c'était
pas suffisant pour nous mais aujourd'hui
il y a plus rien par rapport à ça donc
ça c'est un vrai sujet et puis il faut
traiter l'emploi des seniors puisque là
il y a absolument plus rien tout a été
retoqué là au niveau au niveau de la loi
et aujourd'hui une personne sur deux qui
arrive à la retraite qui n'est plus un
activité c'est absolument impossible de
continuer comme ça parce que c'est la
cause principale de notre de notre
déficit et là est-ce que les mesures que
votées par le Sénat sur l'index seniors
le CDI senior ça vous allez alors le
sédit senior je respire que c'est une
mauvaise mauvaise solution donc ça ne va
pas parce qu'on continue ça fait un peu
le message offrez-vous un seniors à bas
coût ou pas cher enfin je je j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec ce type de mesure
par contre l'index senior oui je suis
persuadé que c'est une bonne mesure mais
c'est une bonne mesure à condition que
les entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu
soient pénalisées à la fin or là c'est
pas contraignant en fait donc là c'est
une mesure ben là c'est une mesure est
en disant c'était pénalisant si
l'entreprise publiez pas son index alors
je peux vous dire moi des index je vous
en publie 300 par jour c'était pas un
problème donc ce qu'on demande de nous à
la CFTC c'est que lorsque l'entreprise
publiera l'index si cette index est
mauvais il doit l'année suivante faire
une progression alors évidemment si on
met que le bon d'index et 80 % et que
l'entreprise est à 40 on va pas le
demander de gagner 40 points d'un an
mais en tout cas peut-être de en trois
quatre ans de gagner 10 points chaque
année voyez d'avoir une trajectoire qui
soit positive sinon d'être pénalisé et
ça vous lui demandez de le réintégrer
très vite dans la future loi travail et
d'aller plus loin puisqu'on demande
d'être pénalisé si l'index ne s'améliore
pas d'année la prochaine action des
syndicats les fixée au 6 juin cette
grande marche nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce que pour vous ça peut
influer sur le vote des députés le 8
juin cette journée du 6 juin oui ça peut
influer il y a ce but oui c'est tout à
fait le but c'est mettre pression sur
les sur les parlementaires à la fois par
la manifestation et puis par le travail
que l'on fait donc on a écrit en inter
syndical à l'ensemble des députés
des sénateurs les républicains oui on
peut ils soutiennent la réforme des
retraites oui alors on rencontre
évidemment on discute avec le groupe
Elliott puis on rencontre à la fois
enfin en tout cas pour la CFTC des
parlementaires des républicains et de la
majorité parce que les autres courants
il y a pas beaucoup enfin il y a pas
besoin de les convaincre à voter la
proposition de loi donc peut-être pas
besoin de perdre du temps avec ce dont
on sait qu'ils vont le voter le groupe
vous allez rencontrer le président le
président m'a écrit on doit se
rencontrer assez assez rapidement
avant non j'ai pas j'ai pas la date on
essaie de de voir avec nos agendas
communs je vous rappelle que sur sur
cette réforme des retraites en nous
disait il y a quelques mois mais elle
sera votée toute façon il faudrait 25
voix des républicains ou 30 voix au
maximum on en compte 10 ou 12 ça ne
marchera pas on a vu que par ses coups
de fil par notre pression au bout du
bout le compte y était pas et même des
députés de la majorité n'auraient pas
voté la loi et c'est pour ça que c'est
par un 49-3 donc je pense qu'il y a une
réelle chance que cette proposition de
là soit votée
parce qu'on a entendu des députés les
républicains qui ont voté la mention de
censure qui sont opposées à cette
réforme être un peu réticent c'est un
euphémisme sur le fait que l'iode soit
si proche des syndicats est-ce que du
coup vous avez pas peur que ça vous
enlève des voix chez les républicains
alors moi je me sens absolument pas
proche du groupe du groupe oyote il y a
juste que par le jeu politique le groupe
Elliott dépose la proposition de loi
parce que c'est le seul groupe qui peut
faire en sorte que tous les autres
groupes votent une proposition de loi on
sait bien que lorsque la nups fait une
proposition de loi le RN a du mal au
voter et inversement donc ce groupe se
retrouve voilà se retrouve à une place
centrale mais moi je me sens pas je me
sens pas proche de d'un groupe je
simplement je fais mon rôle en tant que
leader syndical de demander au
parlementaire et au sénateurs de voter
cette proposition de loi pour que un
article 7 soit supprimé et deux il y a
une autre proposition qui est une grande
conférence de financement et c'est ça
qu'on demande pour encore une fois moi
je ne conteste pas le fait qu'il faille
trouver les 12 15 milliards on dit juste
qu'on peut les trouver autrement est-ce
que vous n'allez pas la demander à
Elisabeth borde demain sans forcément
passer par le vote de cette loi alors ça
va faire partie des choses que vous
demanderez demain on va demander une de
retirer la loi pour faire et la place
une conférence de financement parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence si on n'est
pas à quelques mois près pour faire une
réforme des retraites mais aujourd'hui
la réponse du gouvernement et on le voit
bien hier encore dans la déclaration du
Président on voit bien qu'ils ne veulent
pas bouger sur cette réforme des
retraites donc je crois que la seule
chose maintenant à faire après trois
mois et demi de mobilisation c'est de
passer par cette proposition de loi du
groupe du groupe eliotté le 8 juin vous
êtes optimiste là dessus elle peut être
votée ça va se jouer à quelques voix le
peuple voter à l'Assemblée nationale ça
sera notre sujet au Sénat mais je crois
que ça serait quand même un coup de
tonnerre parce que ça sera la première
fois qu'il y aurait un vote à
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette loi
parce qu'il y a pas eu de
il y a eu un vote contre le sentiment
voté à l'Assemblée nationale mais on
sait tous qu'elle sera pas votée au
Sénat elle sera pas suivi des faits donc
vous cherchez avant tout un coup de com
un coup politique médiatique à travers
ce à travers ce vote non qu'est-ce qui
se passe après c'est pas un coup que ce
sera pas la progression la loi elle-même
même si c'est voté à l'assemblée alors
on peut se mettre d'accord que voter
l'assemblée il y a une chance voter au
Sénat ça va être très compliqué ça
jusqu'à là on est d'accord je crois que
ça serait un coup de tonnerre que ce
soit voté à l'assemblée parce que Claire
et pas un conteneur pour les syndicats
c'est c'est un coup de tonnerre parce
que le président aura quand même du mal
et le gouvernement aurait du mal à nous
dire pour une fois où c'est voté qu'on
ne peut pas complètement tenir compte ça
peut avoir des conséquences dans
lesquelles par exemple ça peut avoir
alors ça peut avoir une conséquence en
me disant que cette loi tout compte fait
en la broche parce que le gouvernement
ne s'attendait pas à ce que cette
proposition de loi le soit votée et ça
va être dur d'expliquer qu'on ferme les
yeux sur ça ça peut avoir des
conséquences politiques parce que un tel
vote d'une proposition de loi à
l'Assemblée ça peut mettre
le gouvernement de difficulté on peut
avoir un changement de gouvernement on
peut on pourrait avoir une dissolution
enfin en tout cas mais vous l'a demandé
vous dites si le texte est voté le 8
juin il faut une dissolution tout le
départ je demande pas le départ
d'isabeth borne je monte pas une
dissolution mais je combats pas le
gouvernement je combat cette loi donc
moi je suis extrêmement clair sur ça
mais dire que un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale aurait que peu d'importance ou
simplement un coup de com non ça peut
faire retirer cette loi parce que ça ça
va être un coutonnèrent ça peut avoir
des conséquences politiques donc si on
mesure tout ça c'est pas ça c'est pas
rien de mais vous avez raison mais même
après les propos du président de la
République hier vous avez vous avez
senti qui qu'il serait prêt à reculer en
cas en cas de de vote pour la
beaugration le 8 juin non mais je crois
qu'il y a aussi un jeu politique pour
tout faire aujourd'hui pour que cette
proposition de loi ne soit pas votée
entre les discours officiels et ce qu'on
entend un peu dans les coulisses c'est
ça les inquiète que cette proposition de
loi puisse être votée parce que
évidemment derrière dans les
justifications ça va être dur de venir
sur les plateaux pour dire non mais
attendez ça a été voté par le Parlement
mais en fait on peut ne pas en tenir
compte ça va être compliqué donc il y a
de il y a de l'inquiétude par rapport à
cette proposition de loi je crois que le
gouvernement fait le pari aujourd'hui
que ça ne sera pas voté pour quelques
voies nous on fait le pari inverse on
verra bien rendez-vous 8 et si jamais
vous perdez votre pari est-ce que vous
acterez la fin de la bataille contre
cette réforme des retraites pour le CFTC
je pense que je pense que le 8 c'est le
dernier combat derrière on passe à
juillet-août ça va être compliqué de
faire des mobilisations puis je crois
qu'au bout d'un moment on aura fait tout
ce qu'on pourrait dire on tourne la page
ce combat là on l'a perdu alors on
tourne la page on continuera à combattre
la réforme des retraites on continuera à
s'exprimer et on continuera à demander
d'avoir des modifications on se battra
aussi sur les décrets d'application dans
lequel on peut faire des modifications
qui sont en train d'être écrit donc on
continuera vous savez mais il y aura pas
de nouvelles journées de mobilisation de
votre part il y aura pas de nouvelles
actions de votre part je ne pense pas
parce que je ne vois pas ce que ça peut
apporter aujourd'hui mais j'a grandir on
continue à critiquer la réforme de 2010
en étant 2023 donc le combat contre
cette réforme on va continuer à le mener
je sous d'autres formes mais sous
d'autres formes je pense pas
déjà en tête ou c'est le prénom on va on
va on va on va y réfléchir on va y
réfléchir ensemble et je vous dis à la
piste des décrets d'applications qui est
important on pourrait demander une
conférence de financement on pourrait je
vous rappelle aussi que les 64 ans c'est
horizon de 2030 et que ami parcours il
doit y avoir un bilan et un état des
lieux qui doit être fait donc c'est
aussi une façon de faire le RIB qui n'a
pas été voté on peut le enfin qui n'a
pas été mise en place et valider on peut
le redemander au bout d'un an suite à la
promulgation de la loi donc ça peut être
aussi une piste à plus à plus long terme
voilà donc il y a tout ça qui est en
réflexion mais appelé encore des
manifestations très massives dans la rue
après le 8
ça me paraît pas ça me paraît pas une
bonne idée est-ce sauf si sauf si le
texte est votre sauf si le texte est
voté là en l'occurrence on devra se
reposer la question est-ce que l'Inter
syndical à vocation a duré
syndical de la s’est construite sur
cette question des 64 ans enfin du refus
des 64 ans aujourd'hui a duré enfin
je dirais oui et non c'est à dire que à
chaque fois qu'on peut être d'accord sur
une thématique autant la portée ensemble
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire on peut porter cette thématique
ensemble après on sait qu'on a aussi des
tas de sujets sur lesquels nous sommes
pas d'accord sur nos propositions et
quand on n'est pas d'accord ben chacun
défend sa proposition et respectent
l'autre voilà ce que vous avez d'autres
combats communs à venir est-ce que vous
êtes en train de préparer autre chose en
intercendicale on discute ensemble sur
sur les sujets qu'on pourrait porter en
commun et on a deux trois sujets
aujourd'hui on sait que la
conditionnalité des aides est un sujet
qu'on peut porter en commun même si on
sera peut-être pas d'accord au bout du
bout sur l'application exacte et qu'on
peut avoir des différences mais en tout
cas le principe on est prêt à le porter
ensemble sur ce que je parlais aussi sur
le fait que les 150 branches qui ont des
niveaux de classification en dessous du
SMIC c'est un sujet qu'on va je pense
porter ensemble donc voilà on se parle
des retraites bien sûr il y a d'autres
actions communes alors action commune
non là aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans la
on travaille sur quels sont les sujets
qu'on peut porter ensemble je vous en ai
cité deux il peut y avoir d'autres sur
l'assurance chômage par exemple ou
d'autres sujets quand on est
parfaitement d'accord sur un sujet ou en
tout cas ou contre une une mesure ça
peut être aussi par cet effet-là autant
le porter ensemble on est toujours plus
fort maintenant on a beaucoup de
différence et ce qui est bien ce qu'on a
appris d'être mieux à se connaître on
respecte nos différences et on respecte
nos désaccords et ça aussi c'est
important
on sait que tous les syndicats ont
profité on profite de ce mouvement il y
a des regains d'adhésion est-ce que
c'est le cas la CFTC comment vous le
mesurez oui on a eu 30% d'adhésion
supplémentaire sur les quatre premiers
mois et pour discuter régulièrement avec
avec mes autres collègues leaders
syndicaux on est à peu près tous dans
ces dans ces eaux là c'est à dire que
chacune des organisations syndicales a
eu un boom assez important de 30% ce
n'est pas rien un ça va se retrouver
vous pensez que c'est une nouvelle
dynamique alors je crois qu'il y a une
nouvelle dynamique et on a montré notre
notre sérieux durant durant ce conflit
après traditionnellement les conflits
apportent des adhésions supplémentaires
mais pas de ce niveau là donc je crois
qu'il y a une vraie dynamique maintenant
il faut pas décevoir il faut s'occuper
des salariés au début de la
reconstruction d'un rapport de force oui
oui c'est je pense que c'est un nouveau
rapport de force merci c'est merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin Stéphane la ligne 12 France
migrants les États-Unis plongés dans la
confusion c'est-à-dire elle a une de
votre journal merci Stéphane merci Cyril
chavani on passe au club des territoires